welcome to this video for the final
round of the candidates tournament this
is about the game to pull off playing
white against a Drake in playing black
yeah for the power off it's been a
rotten tournament he's on - - after he
lost against Kramnik in the penultimate
round while and Drake in his own 50%
after he had beaten aronia in the same
the same route just yesterday for him
certainly this 50% is is a success I
mean I don't think he was seriously
expecting to to qualify I don't know I
mean how to tell what players do expect
but 50% is certainly a result that he
should be okay with I believe so let's
see what happens in this game we have
double King pawn opening and slightly
surprising the Berlin and raking has
played this but it's not one of his his
main openings yet the power plays d3
he's some sometimes playing the the
endgame with white but this time doing
for the d3 line Bishop c5 and here he
played castles which is a bit uncommon
simply because in people usually choose
between c3 and the capture the caption
going for this kind of structure
sometimes with Bishop III for example or
c3 c3 has a very concrete idea it
prevents the move Knight to deform it's
not just a general kind of schematic
move it's really having a direct idea
because it is belief that after let's
say castles what token of plate 94
should equalize rather comfortably this
happened and yeah why it is belief that
it should equal as comfortably it's due
to this commonly known fact that in the
opening games quite often the knight on
six which is of course a necessary move
for move - okay you can play the petrov
but I mean it's now it's protecting a
five of the sleep and very often in a
later stage you find that the knight on
c6 is not such a great piece if white
puts the pawn on c3s all those squares
that the knight looks at are protected
so this exchange very often means that
black can has gained something this is
also happening in some other lines in
the in the Spanish if we for example
look at this line the very old-fashioned
Bishop c5 line which is not entirely bad
actually castles and 94 here again this
okay there are some some technical ideas
here for white but generally speaking
this should be an okay position okay we
get to this but the polyp has a very
concrete idea he's not playing this with
the idea to will not set any problems
he's doing with the move Knight to a3
which is not new but very much forgotten
line it's got some idea of course right
here it basically provokes c6 but let's
move that black wants to play anyhow the
ship back and now castles yeah what is
the knight doing on a3 as mentioned
there is this idea but the knight can
also be used in this way regrouping it
to e3 and what it also does is it's not
blocking the c1 Bishop if you were look
at this in comparison if white would now
play here the bishop is simply blocked
and this allowed white to play Bishop g5
in this position so you quickly get the
bishop out and this is a slightly
annoying pin black cannot yeah black
cannot break the pin with this bishop
it's on b6
he would I guess and some way would
prefer to have the bishop on his seventh
Oh that you're not not pestered by this
but I'm dragging finds a good way to to
counter it he plays age six first the
ship back and now d5 this is of course
also a positive effect of this night's
trade the knight from c6 after the
knight from c6 is gone and you have a c6
played you can even go for us is sixty
five sometimes and this worked out well
now the night on a3 is looking a bit
silly but it will get back into play to
power of takes and place Bishop b3 this
is I think a good idea to take it's a
it's looking a bit yeah I don't know
a bit strange maybe at her site but it
gives white something to attack the
black center black now must decide what
to do about the kingside situation this
pin is just quite an annoying knowing
feature of the position he plays even g5
here and this is probably a good news
move like Bishop e6 is also playable
covering d5 but after let's say just a
simple move rook e1
what are you doing about your pawn you
probably have to play this g5 any way
you can cover like that but I can even
attack the center with c4 him yeah like
d4 95 it's it's a good idea to play d5
get this sorted once and for all this
pin drop back and now rupee eight you
know now it's a bit similar to the line
before but here black is flexible with
this Bishop on c8 so black has the
slight weakness on the King side but
he's got center control and active
pieces I am thinking that it is probably
around equal
yeah d4 is an ambitious move for any by
and Dracon but maybe you can play that
why does not very aggressively post it
maybe he was a bit concerned about 93
coming so this d4 move let's the
midnight look a bit silly but on the
other hand it and livens the the bishop
on b3 so kind of a kind of yeah
double-edged decision this fairly
logical got thus traded and now with d4
white gets rid of his d4 pawn IDC tries
to do that check yeah it's a completely
symmetrical pawn structure now in terms
of majorities two against two or three
against three
the only thing that really makes this
position special is that like has played
there was a weakening moves on them on
the Kings side with the night having
this idea to enter on f5 this could be a
big problem but there are just concrete
things happening here 95 is the the
point attacking the Queen and well the
Queen is now going to f3 which um looks
perfectly logical and it's not clear
where where outs actually where we are
switch you go this is quite quite
similar to the game after this there was
also Queenie for played and this is the
important point that black needed to
anticipate that now you are getting the
Queen's off him
white least you will in the very near
future this wasn't played but this is an
is an important point to pile of went
for something else he went to Knight f5
immediately and this is basically
winning a pawn as
after the capture and here it's not
impossible we need to keep h6 and yes to
maintain a harmonious position if you go
King edge 7 just just to show it what is
going here and set up this pin and this
is a very very problematic it will even
lose material you have a hard time to
prevent this so like must address that
first and place route to d8 and okay
this gives up a pawn wide can now take
h6 with a check check but in the process
blacks King gets activated to g6 and he
has rather active pieces this Bishop is
potentially good here no it can go here
can go on a form and well after all
white rights the pawn that he has won is
one of those airports and they're not
going to Queen anytime soon we got some
some more moves in and black is
basically just staying and awaits
developments the problem is for white
that this night only six is just
blocking the F corneum and you're not
going to make any headway we've got
routes traded no f5 yeah now black is
even trying to play a form shutting out
the bishop so what goes out of that of
course and after f4 I think we are all
already very close to having a sort of
position of the draw it's very hard to
imagine how black should lose the
position we it continued for quite a
long while black is basically just
staying and doing nothing I mean there
is simply nothing that you can do the
night only six is perfectly placed and
they shuffled a lot the problem is
certainly trying to do something you
would love to get a winnin
but it is simply not possible to do
anything yeah we got got Knights traded
and so that didn't agree to a draw but
very soon ish let's say I think he he
round yeah here they actually agreed to
a draw
yeah there's absolutely no headway like
if some always attacking those two
points with the king and why this is
making no progress whatsoever
um yeah are not the most exciting game
in a way but if we look at this probably
this idea this Knight e3 idea is not
setting like so much problems but he
needed to play this ends energetic
approach with g5 to to prove that he is
actually actually okay yeah
to sum up the tournament for both
players terrible for top I love quite
good I know maybe really good for under
18 I don't know I don't know what
ambition he had before the event but I
think he can be quite quite satisfied
with this performance alright I hope you
enjoyed this brief coverage of the game
anyway thanks for watching